- We are here with Rachel McAdams, y'all,
(audience cheering)
Abby Ryder Fortson, and Judy Blume.
The new movie is called
Are You There God? It's me, Margaret.
It's in theaters tomorrow.
And there are some points in the movie
when Abby's character deals
with a group of friends
that almost feels a
little like Mean Girls.
So, Rachel, my favorite thing
that I say on this show is I love,
you're one of my favorite
actors of our generation
because you go from Regina
George to a detective
to a mom in this movie,
and you play a wide range of characters,
which I find interesting.
Are you purposeful with that?
Like in choosing what
roles you choose to do?
- I try to be,
yeah.
- Yeah?
- I think it lends to better performance.
You know, if you're not bored,
you're not repeating yourself.
- [Kelly] Yeah, (indistinct).
There's, you know, you're like,
I don't quite understand this.
I'm gonna' have to work
really hard to figure it out.
- Yeah.
- And you know, for me,
variety's the spice of life,
like I'm not a creature of habit at all.
- Yeah.
- Love to go around the
world, see different places.
- Yeah.
- It's something different every day.
I'm just, that's just
the way I'm geared, so.
And like you said,
to get to live many lifetimes in one
is one of the best things that,
I don't know if you feel
that way as a writer as well.
- You do.
- I was just gonna' say
that when you're writing,
you are living, you know.
- (indistinct).
- You are having all of these experiences
and you are living other lives.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- And it in a way, it's
like acting, you know?
- Right.
- Because I, when I was young,
I wanted to be an actor,
but I never trained or did anything.
(Abby laughing)
But-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Writing fulfills that
because I am every character.
- Mm-hmm. I think writing songs, same way.
Yeah.
Even if it's about you,
it's like different chapters of your life.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think that writing is so therapeutic.
Is that one of the reasons
why you love to write?
It's therapeutic for me.
- It was, it changed my life
and it saved my life and-
- [Kelly] Yeah, me too.
- came along at just the right time.
- Yeah.
I feel very fortunate
'cause not everybody has that outlet.
And I feel very fortunate to have it.
- It was great for me.
It was.
- Yeah.
It's great for us too, turns out.
(women laughing)
Yeah.
(audience laughing)
Thank you as well.